welche sprache haben die römer
gesprochen römisch-katholische grund
soll die leute bei dem ich glaube ich
eine ganze menge spaß haben wäre die
kurze vorgeschichte dazu meine freundin
hat mich auf dem video hingewiesen und
zwar von aaron troschke indem er einen
influenza idiotentest gemacht hat und
das ich mir dieses video nochmal
anschauen soll das mache ich heute leute
und sie hat mir schon gesagt ich werde
mir den kopf fassen und irgendwas
irgendwas sagt mir irgendeine vögelchen
zwitschern mir grad vom nachbar darf
dass ich tatsächlich heute wieder massiv
an der menschheit zweifel werde aber
schon bevor wir mit dem video anfang
noch eine sache leute und zwar werde ich
ab heute eine richtig coole aktion
starten ich werde alle leute die mir
geile video ideen für action schicken
belohnen und zwar wenn ich die video
idee tatsächlich nehme bekommt diese
person einen 10 euro amazon gutschein
hat eben nur wenn die idee wirklich geil
ist und ich die auch wenn man kann passt
deswegen könnte ein bisschen mitdenken
also wenn ich nehme bekommt ihr das auch
also macht euch gedanken und wenn ihr
wirklich eine gute idee habt ihr auch
main kanal rein passt dann schickt sie
an idee für skf outlook punkt kommt ja
auch noch mal eingeblendet und dann habt
ihr vielleicht glücklich nehme und dann
bekommt ihr den 10 euro gutschein für
freunde der sonne willkommen zu einem
neuen video ich bin ja beim kreisklassen
paar dreh dabei und ich dachte mir das
sind doch alles schüler den stelle ich
meine schüler frank und mal gucken
schlau die sind sie aber auch man sieht
mehrere sachen hier direkt erstens wie
krass aaron troschke vorproduziert im
november hat er das aufgenommen und lebt
ist im januar hoch musste ich aber schon
hinter den kulissen der typ ist glaube
ich fast vom produktion angeht den
organisation und man muss auch dazu
sagen leute an alle leute die in dieser
bilanz auftauchen vielleicht nicht so
gut weg kommt ich möchte die nicht
persönlich kannten oder so jeder hat so
seine eigenen stärken seine schwächen so
ihr wisst was ich meine dass ich keine
angegriffen fühlen aber und es mit
sicherheit auch gute leute schlecht
dastehen zu lassen aber wie viel grad
hatten gestreckter winkel
0 63 ein gestreckter winkel ist jetzt
auch erster muss ich sagen ich mache den
mathetest parallel mit ist das erste
begriff der mir persönlich nichts sagt
ich kenne spitze winkel stumpfen winkel
rechte winkel gestreckter winkel würde
ich sagen 180 grad also einfach so aber
der begriff ist mir persönlich noch nie
untergekommen in mathe abitur
wirtschaftsmacht in der uni was ich
alles aber mal schauen kannst du ja
immer sagen wie viel grad ein
gestreckter winkel hat keine keine
schlauen aufgaben so schulaufgaben kann
ich gar nicht kenne keine schlauen
aufgaben okay gut ist aber das ist auch
also ich bin mir sicher leute für alle
die wir noch nicht gesehen haben ich
habe auch noch nicht gesehen
mir wurde von meiner freundin gesagt es
gibt noch krassere fragen hier drin also
einfache fragen die möglicherweise
falsch beantwortet werden 80 grad null
grad ist ja quasi also wissen 90 03 10
mal so egal egal ob kommen das endspiel
in kraft trat du bist eine schülerin
paar sachen muss wissen wer bereits erst
auf mond okay okay
die erste bemannte raumfahrt also im
weltall haben glaube ich die russen es
gab so eine russische hunde laika oder
so sie war glaube ich das erste
lebewesen der welt räumt ist dann auch
gestorben
tritt die ersten leute auf dem mond
waren die amerikaner das war buzz aldrin
oder
wie heißt du denn da ist armstrong aber
nicht louis das ist ein musiker längst
ist ein fahrradfahrer am samstag mit
welchen körperteil atmend fische mit dem
team im blick sein bruder ja leute was
noch mal dazu sagen
noch haben wir nicht genug zu sehen um
sagen zu können dass es um die bildung
unserer influenza in deutschland nicht
optimal bestellt ist aber auch der
höchste berg der welt
das ist nicht so schlau fragen die man
eigentlich also also nicht mit seinen
schlauen fragen stellen wir dumme fragen
fünf konsonanten komm schon konsonanten
stn haben schon fünf kannst mir doch
sicher fünf konsonanten nennen
ja ok aber aber ich muss auch sagen ich
glaube da ist auch einfach mit dem
schnitt ein bisschen gearbeitet worden
also jonas würde ich auf jeden fall
zutrauen also ich kenne jonas ems dass
er das richtig beantworten kann so aber
hat er kurz wissen überlegt so und ich
weiß jetzt eine antwort kommt aber so
kann man natürlich auch so aussehen
lassen als wüsste er die antwort gar
nicht kommt konnten mit lauter
die werden kommen mit laute gesagt hätte
bitte jetzt bitte leute sollte kommt
kommt schon die und kanal wir youtuber
ich vielleicht auch ein teil davon sehr
irgendwo ein bisschen so vorbilder auch
für deutschland dann muss man ja auch in
der hinsicht eigentlich ein bisschen
ich muss aber auch sagen früher früher
habe ich das auch manchmal die standard
vokale und konsonanten ich merke einfach
so sogar ein bisschen latein so im kopf
hat so korn heißt ja mit und
wahrscheinlich so nah ist klingen oder
so was also mit klingt kann aber nicht
sondern es also der klinken e mit
deswegen ist ein konsument so in meinem
kopf bruder
[Musik]
genau kann ich jetzt mit neuer kraft
klassenerhalt machen
ich hätte ich jetzt sagen kann du sag
mal kannst du mir fünf konsonanten kommt
konnte man ja sorry sind natürlich
deswegen ist es keine hobbys league eine
schlecht menschen ist ja auch ganz klar
leute aber so paar sachen sollte man
halt eigentlich schon wissen weil man
hat ja auch irgendeine verantwortung als
interessant dass man den leuten keinen
schluss erzählt uns was ja stimmt stimmt
stimmt aber auch zweimal das richtig
okay okay vielleicht sind ja auch noch
gewissen themengebieten
welche sprache haben die römer
gesprochen
[Musik]
oder ich glaube ich wirklich glaube ich
krieg geraten schlaganfall ich es fühlt
sich immer im kopf so an als würde ich
ein schlaganfall jetzt bekommen gerade
die römer sprechende römisch katholisch
ich dachte der katholizismus wenn der
religion aber einmal ist eine sprache ok
alles klar gemacht
[Musik]
und da sollen die germanische doch
niemals visier
ich bin gerade ernsthaft geschockt also
wirklich ich kann das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass muss also bei den beiden
jonas die idee hatte ich schon die haben
schon was im kopf so wie andere auch ein
unternehmen gegründet im hintergrund
sodass ist das unternehmen was krass
klassenfahrt und produziert so und so
weiter und so fort
ist deren unternehmen das haben selbst
gegründet mit anfang 20 also ich dir
dient es kann doch nicht sein liga
sprechen
[Musik]
sind die leute die deutschlands jugend
beeinflussen und prägen und die
vorbilder für die machen was leute und
die römer haben welche sprache
gesprochen oder das kannst du mir nicht
erzählt nein das glaube ich nicht nein
ich glaube ich glaube es nicht ich
glaube die waren jonas so die machen das
glaube ich nicht dass ein also ja
natürlich ich sag's doch mal über teilen
ist klar aber es kann nein nein ich weiß
nicht
oder nein einfach nein also man kann
eine sache zusammenfassen leute die ich
auch schon so oft gesagt aber noch öfter
sagen will hinterfragt auch jedenfalls
an denen ihr folgt so denkmal bisschen
selber nach weil einige von denen nicht
zwingend dir im video sind aber einige
von denen da draußen leute sind wirklich
überhaupt nicht auf der höhe aber sowas
von überhaupt nicht noch mal explizit
sich die im video aber da sind einige da
draußen ja ok schreiben jetzt in die
kommentare wie viele von den fragen ihr
richtig oder falsch beantwortet hätte
und deutsche team für euch vorstandes
wie die abonnierte um ein knappes gut